packed with a cast of young 80 stars
joel schumacher's The Lost Boys all but
founded the idea that vampires could be
sexy well not without its fair share of
cheese The Lost Boys is aged pretty well
but what about the cast
well stars Corey Haim Edward Herrmann
Brooke MacArthur and Bernhard Hughes of
sadly passed away since its release Lost
Boys boasts a huge cast to catch up with
here's what the Lost Boy stars have been
up to over the past few decades Kiefer
Sutherland of all the Lost Boys Kiefer
Sutherland has maintained his household
name status the best even if people
don't know that his full name is
actually Kiefer william frederick
Dempsey George Rufus Sutherland
that was a mouthful it previously
starred in stand by me but it was his
role as David the vampire that first
secured Sutherlands future status in
Hollywood he quickly went on to appear
in a slew of major motion pictures
including young guns flat liners and a
time to kill he also starred as the lead
in the mega hit TV series 24
most recently Sutherland returned to the
small screen for a similar drama series
called it's designated survivor and
he'll even appear in the Flatliners
reboot Corey Feldman in some ways Corey
Feldman never had a childhood known for
his roles in gremlins The Goonies are
stand by me and the burbs
Feldman like his Lost Boys co-star and
real-life friend Corey Haim in jord
tumultuous early years he told the
Chicago Tribune most people in society
are all given equal rights to decide
what their future should be I never had
the opportunity that's been reflected in
the tabloid reports sort of dogged
Feldman as an adult in 2013 vice
published a now infamous first-hand
account of a shindig at his crib
dubbed the feldmansion describing a
raucous affair where scantily clad women
wearing only lingerie attend for free
while men can pay for entry and private
angel service whatever that entails he
also had lines as a musical stage act
called Corey's angels and has bitten
back at criticisms of his new
professional adventure a lot of people
get hate in the beginning because we're
doing something new it hasn't been done
before but it's all about innovation and
being an artist and we can't be afraid
to share our art
Jason Patric in his breakout role
Jason Patric played Michael the high
some protagonist who gives in to peer
pressure chug some vampire blood and
becomes a sunglasses wearing bloodsucker
who sleeps all day after defeating is
for your life friend Kiefer Sutherland
on the big screen and stealing his
real-life fiance Julia Roberts Patrick
went on to nab some other memorable
roles he played Jim Raynor in rush
shakes and sleepers officer Alex Shore
and speed to cruise control and to dr.
Theo yet Lynn in wayward Pines to name a
few but Patrick's most recent time in
the media spotlight has been pretty
unrelated to his career he fought a
heated custody battle with his
ex-girlfriend Daniel Schreiber after
donating his sperm to her and fighting
for his parental rights to the resulting
child shared custody was ultimately
offered for the kid in question but not
before Schreiber accused Patrick of
having been physically and verbally
abusive to her and prompting another
legal spectacle between them for what
it's worth
Patrick still remembers his time on the
Lost Boys fondly it's just nice had all
those years later I'm still very good
for entertaining Curt
very good friends at Kiefer and it was a
special time Dianne Wiest before landing
the role of Lucy in The Lost Boys Dianne
Wiest was already fairly well known for
a roles as by Moore in Footloose Polly
and Hannah and her sisters and be in
radio days but afterwards she continued
to accelerate her character actress
status by appearing in bullets over
Broadway ron howard's parenthood edward
scissorhands
i am sam and more despite having an
extensive list of credits and pair of
Academy Awards for Best Supporting
Actress in her trophy cabinet Wiest
claims her career has been hampered by
being typecast in the type of mother
role we see her play in The Lost Boys
she told the New York Times are the only
office she ever gets us to play a nice
mom and that's in great with all of you
indeed her current starring role
features her as just that in the small
screen series life in pieces Jami Gertz
before appearing in The Lost Boys Jami
Gertz had already starred in the facts
of life and sixteen Candles
however girls career really took off
after playing star in The Lost Boys she
immediately went on to play Monica Tom
Manske and listen to me Tobey and Jersey
girl and the Lilly Ruscio in the
television series acip's she also
appeared as dr. Melissa Reeves in the
blockbuster tornado drama twister before
landing the recurring roles of dr. Nina
Pomerantz in
and Kimi Bishop and Ally McBeal most
recently Gert starred in the small
screen series the neighbors along with
other Network cameos Jamison neulander
not every Lost Boys star has been able
to break out of the film shel Jamison
neulander is still known for his role as
Alan frog in the film and doesn't boast
as much star power as some of his former
co-stars he told Collider people don't
necessarily recognize me right away
because I look a little different when
they realize I'm a frog brother and I
was in The Lost Boys it's exciting in
addition to playing the less famous Frog
brother in the first film neulander also
reprised his role for the sequels back
when Joel and Cory and I got together
and we were like coming up with these
characters you know something about it
really worked and spoke to people
Billy Werth after playing the tall scary
vampire who takes an arrow to the chest
and gets fried by a stereo Billy Werth
has kept himself busy even if he never
quite reached samake status of his other
fanged friends he appeared in the list
of films that includes Body Snatchers
and boys on the side while also making
appearances on shows like Sex in the
City
Alex winter after playing Marco in The
Lost Boys Alex winter went on to play
another of the most iconic roles of the
80s as one half of the title pair in
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure movies
though he's done a few other things as
well
he'll probably always be best known for
that role and the winter doesn't mind it
much in fact even he is not ready to
retire his goofy time-traveling
adventure series just yet he told The
Next Web that the third installment of
Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure is
coming soon saying the fun thing about
them is that they're ageless you play
them in terms of who they are
spiritually their mannerism and
physicality are not tied to age we
played them like nine year olds it will
be funnier because they're older
zwei thanks for watching click the loop
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out with us cool stuff we
know your love to
[Applause]
you